if I'm looking at my newsfeed how come
the outcome of a vote or a referendum is
so different to what I'm expecting it to
be all right so it's because all the
people that post their opinions of
what's going to happen of people that
you've made friends with and they're
producing a kind of filter bubble which
is showing you all the same information
that you think just shared by other
people who think the same thing of you
and it's a phenomenon of who you've made
friends with in this what information
that filters towards you through
Facebook this is an interesting social
media phenomenon that we we've seen
research about for a while now and the
people who are investigating for how to
deal with because what you've
experienced there is called a social
media filter bubble and it's the way the
technology is affecting the information
we see on a day to day basis and here we
see it from and who we talk to and it's
based on several theories of how we
develop friendships and things like that
but it's really a kind of increasingly
well-established phenomenon that we
essentially make friends with people
that we know and like a similar to us
and then all the information we see on a
daily basis is coming from those people
who have the same opinions as we do so
it's exactly one of the two inches of
things that we've been seeing lately on
referendums and voting is that our
Facebook feed feels very very different
to the national outcome so without
discussing you know sides and the
outcomes and votes it's just interesting
to see that the votes have come out
differently to what a lot of people
expect or it's just been a lot closer
than we expect and that so either side
of how you see what happened it was
really close and you don't see the same
balance likely in your Facebook feed
let's talk about who we make friends
with this is an interesting set of
theories as to what what affects who we
choose to talk to and looks like there's
several things like attractiveness or
reciprocity of sharing information with
each other or just helping each other
with things these will find but two key
ones location so who will likely to run
into and also similarity now the
similarity one is different is
interesting and what effect it has there
was a nice quote that I found so
similarity includes having similar
attitudes values interests and beliefs
while also being of similar
gender socioeconomic status education
and attractiveness has come up again so
we're good friends because we're both
very attractive but that similarity
statement is quite interesting so social
economic status interests values these
are all the things that affects you know
maybe who we would vote for which or
what things we vote for but it means
that if we're friends with a lot of
people who are similar to us then we see
those same values coming out now over
and over again and so this is what's
affecting the the social media filter
bubble is what we want is that what it
is
well if part of it is self-satisfaction
and getting what we want from our
friends and social networks but to
understand how we can design technology
to affect this or change this or to give
us a more balanced view of what's
happening in the world there's several
things we might want to look at several
theories that will help us look at it
one of them is just the theories of
communication and they're kind of major
types of communication we have with
people there's interpersonal
communication which is two or more
people talking to each other in a kind
of continuous varying dialogue which is
fine and then the other is masked
broadcasts which is they're kind of the
opposite perspective where one person is
talking and everyone else is sort of
receiving and so when a politician goes
on TV and says something this is
broadcast and when we talk to each other
in our homes this is interpersonal
communication and one of these
challenges of what's happening on social
media is that we're sort of trying to do
be interpersonal but we are doing
broadcasts let's bear that in mind the
one thing the second is based on common
ground theory so whenever we talk to
someone we have this kind of concept of
what the other person knows and if we
say something how they'll receive it so
when I talk to some people about
technology I take it at quite a high
level so expect them not to understand
the detail but to be interested in the
reasons in the concepts behind it but
then we need to talk to another nerd you
start talking about low level things
that only you two would find interesting
but it means that when we say something
in a group we're friends we would first
maybe say something to kind of estimate
how they might respond to an issue so if
you say something bold about your
opinion of politics then
will they think the same thing as you
and then once you have a good estimate
that you would then choose what you say
so we always have this kind of
continuous gradient of estimating how
much to say about what we think and
whether you can make a casual joke about
it and now they let's take that or not
this is fine if we're in an
interpersonal real life setting but
challenging when we are online on
Facebook
honestly like that and we're not quite
sure who's gonna see it so then there's
the size of our friendship networks is
the interesting thing there's something
called the Dunbar number which is a
social science unknown number or Social
Psychology we're on a number which
estimates that we can manage about 150
friendships at most some they say
between 100 and 250 but people tend to
zero in on the kind of 115 and this
isn't strong strong relationships but
vegetative people that we can sort of
chatter and catch up and then carry on
with normal and then as we get more
people people start sliding off 150 and
going elsewhere but what we have on
facebook is a lot more people now Dunbar
has done some more research more
recently saying that it doesn't help us
manage more real life connections but he
acknowledges that we have mostly a lot
more people listening to us you might
have 300 friends on Facebook you might
have 500 0 celebrities have thousands
who whatever um but it just means that
whatever we say we are not only saying
to more people than we can normally have
a normal friendship with we're saying it
to a broader audience which encourages
this mass communication
there's also interesting Facebook study
done by Bernstein at our 2013 where they
analyzed how many people you think see
your Facebook posts such as a Facebook
study and they found that we estimate
about 27% of the actual number of people
who see it so if we think 27 people saw
it a hundred people saw it so we have
this huge underestimation of who will
see whatever we say online as well as
who the audience is and to an estimated
so what does this mean for us this means
that when we're on Facebook and we're
talking about politics we are trying to
say into personal things with somebody
who we think shares our same opinion but
we're broadcasting it to a much
audience than when normally were used to
and we're in this very binary status of
share not share and we don't have this
kind of gradient of share certain things
certain people the other effect this has
had then on things like the referendum
or elections that it's created a lot
more difference between people or it's
divided people more because we've said
things in a very broad cast politician
type way that we might only say normally
to someone who's a friends at home or we
would choose have said differently to a
friend to another friend so the impact
this then has on filter bubbles is that
it exaggerated saw filter bubbles we
might unfollow someone on Facebook not a
said dear friend then we'll just turn
off their posts so we don't see
something we disagree with or something
we don't find interesting and so we
specialize our filter bubble to even
more what we want to see and here we
want to hear it from and it creates the
divides even more as to what's happening
and we have a less realistic view of the
whole world then so what we have to do
with technology is figure out how to how
and when we should affect that which
means there's a lot of research at the
moment looking at how do you manipulate
filter balls how often should you bring
in different types of content it's the
kind of thing that set off the Facebook
emotion study that got lots of negative
press and they were trying to say if we
slightly manipulates the Facebook feed
to have different types of content
positive negative or different political
views then what effects does have on
people so there's a lot of research
going into how can we build an algorithm
which samples different people's points
of view but while still being something
you find comfortable and interesting
because of course we get a lot of social
personal value from Facebook that makes
us happy it's a lot of what to do with
well being than it is to do about
political communications does that mean
that maybe someones thinks that being an
activist that the computer science side
of things is is causing that perhaps
just not to go to yeah so the the
algorithm is optimized to show you
things that you're likely to like and
it's optimized to kind of later on and
show you things if you continue to look
and you want to see more and more to
then bringing other stuff that you might
not normally press the like button on so
sort of means that if we say something
then the majority of people in your
Facebook filter bubble who are already
on your side anyway probably just see a
small statement and maybe like it and
then the people who wouldn't have liked
it probably wouldn't see it so it's it
all exaggerated the filter bubble and so
the question is can we design algorithms
which are more varied or sample
variation in the right rates or bring in
different types of opinions at the right
sort of times give you balanced views or
know when to give you balanced views
it's a huge opportunity because we're in
this massive social technology space
where it's mediating the vast majority
of our communication but yet it's
optimized one way not kind of in a
balanced way the problem is that if I
obtain a cookie of you which is supposed
to be secure then I can send that to
let's say Amazon or to a shop and say
I'm sure and please you know what's in a
shopping basket what's his address
what's his credit card details